courtney is in the shining veil it's
really good i'm up to episode three and
enjoying it and i'm up to episode seven
i really love that i love it i get to be
you know a dry sense of humor a mom of a
17 year old which you know it's not easy
in itself and uh she's going through
menopause she's depressed she is
possessed and no one believes her and uh
she has an affair and tries to bring her
family back together so i it is the most
layered character i've ever played all
right let me ask you a question about
this possession stuff
you're on record as saying you lived in
a house in like i don't know laurel
canyon somewhere i don't know yeah
uh it was a home you bought years ago
you bought it from carol king
mm-hmm yeah carol king live there gypsy
rose lee
and you've been in interviews and you've
said
you know i lived in a house that was
haunted do you really believe in ghosts
and that your house was haunted i want
to know the truth okay i really didn't
believe in ghosts but that scared me
when that many people had seen spirits
and stuff in the house and then just out
of the blue not people you know that no
one was the guy wasn't staying in the
house he just rang the doorbell and saw
one standing behind me so that was but i
didn't wait a second yeah some guy rang
your doorbell yeah
mm-hmm and you said to the guy hey
have you heard that this house is fun
the doorbell ring i went to it it was a
ups guy or federal express whatever it
was and i answered it got my package and
he said
do you know this house is haunted
and i go
really why he goes because there's
someone standing behind you
and i thought oh [ __ ] do i have it right
that you then called carol king the
former owner of the house
and had her come over and held a seance
with her to get rid of the ghost first
you know what she came over before that
and i didn't really believe but she's
such a cool lady and i was so in awe of
her
that we did have a seance i i guess it
was we called it we held hands we sat
around and i just wasn't really
connected to it i just kept looking at
her like
this is carole king
and this was the house where carol king
uh shot the famous cover to tapestry
right yeah um she told me there was a
really really bad divorce in the house
and that's when i believe but i did have
a scare in london recently
like i believed in it now i now do
believe what do you mean it's scary i
just got in there so yeah i was a little
jet-lagged but i wasn't sleeping and i
was
sitting there and i closed my eyes to
try to sleep and all of a sudden i saw
these really scary
faces
like old faces and i was like okay stop
stop you got to stop and all of a sudden
i was like mom dad
any m i don't know just kept saying all
these weird things and i saw lights and
the plant was moving next to me and i
said giant wake up
i'm seeing spirits and he had all these
waves around him too and he goes
courtney you are
you're asleep i said no i just woke you
up how can i be asleep and he said well
i'm asleep there are no ghosts
and i i did see them for sure and the
next night i came into the room and i
said look
and i'm going to sound crazy but i said
thanks for visiting last night that was
fun
do not come back tonight because i have
to sleep and i didn't see them again but
think about london it is a a plethora of
old and dead people and you're saying
the ghost respected you when you said
listen it's time for you to leave the
ghost said okay i'm i'm out of here yeah